[Applause]
live from the headquarters of ramsy
solutions it's the ramsy show where we
help people build wealth do work that
they love and create actual amazing
relationships Merry Christmas folks
we're so glad you're with us thanks for
hanging out Jade washaw Ramsey
personality is my co-host today she is
the author of our brand new Ramsey quick
read money's not a math problem the real
reason you're broke and what to do about
it and a whole 57 Pages you can jump
through it at a one setting and it's a
great these little quick reads we put
out I've got several of them on uh Entre
leadership to sub subjects and uh I got
one coming out on real estate we got a
couple of others running around Dr John
deloney did one on anxiety that did real
well and so we got a lot of these little
if you want to do quick little it's
about basically a chapter a good solid
chapter 76 Pages Dave come on now it's
how much 76 P 76 I called it 57 give me
my page numbers now Dave brought you up
short sorry about that don't bring her
up short there's a lot of quality there
in those other 20 pages I left out don't
don't do that so anyway you can check
all that out at Ramsey solutions.com
this year uh this will be uh the next
couple days will be our last live
broadcast of this calendar year uh we we
don't work between Christmas and New
Year so you guys get best ofs uh that's
how that works and so this year we will
have done
242 live shows wow uh we will have taken
over 3,200 callers this year and 184
debt-free screams totaling $36 million
whoa of debt-free yells on the air not
bad pretty cool stuff and uh yesterday
we discovered that the Ramsey show is
the number one podcast in the entire
World on Apple uh all of Apple not just
one of the little nuanced Corners the
whole thing uh so however many 3 million
podcasts there are or something like
that you guys have spread the word you
guys have let your friends and neighbors
know and you've subscribed and shared
and done all the appropriate festar
reviews and you got it for us thank you
thank you for getting us to number one
we appreciate you very very much we
appreciate how many of you that are out
there and that we're here to serve the
phone number here is 8825
5225 Sarah is with us in Minneapolis hi
Sarah welcome to the Ramsey
Show hi Dave thank you for taking my
call sure what's
up um I am wondering my husband's
employer he has a job he's a contract
employee who works seasonally um and
assuming that his job gets renewed for
contract every year his employer has to
pay for his housing for um April through
September and then we also own a home
but in a different state when he's not
working his contract job and so we're
wondering at this point we owe about
$100,000 on our home and it's worth
about
$250,000 if we were to sell it we're
wondering if we should sell our home and
rent from October through uh like
February when he's not in employee
housing and hope his contract keeps
getting renewed or if we should continue
to hang on to this home and just you
know pay the mortgage so every year
there's this three or four month
Gap yes yeah off seon if you will what
does he
do he plays baseball oh okay that makes
sense all right ding ding all right
um how long contract being renewed just
basically he's got to make the team
again is what it amounts to right yeah
they have to you know he has to be
resigned which hopefully he will be
refined
butb he could be let go at any time and
Pi up another team in another
location hopefully yeah
okay how long has he been
playing this will be the sixth year with
the org that we're in so Triple
A yes yes
sir so um is the TR can can do you have
objectivity on his career or are you
emotionally involved and don't know
what's really going on I mean is where's
he where's he headed is he going to make
it the Big
Show well everybody hopes they're going
to that's why I ask if you had
objectivity six years yeah uh is is
their trajectory heading that way or is
he just kind of hanging out in the in
the Triple
A uh it let's see this last year ended
his last or his first season in Triple A
so we've been moving up I mean everybody
hopes they make it to the bigs but he's
not like a top prospect if that you know
yeah okay so that he's had one year in
tripa a the rest of them are in
double yes okay yeah
H gosh I don't
um basically the answer to your question
is what do you think the
probability is that you're going to need
this house and um you you don't know the
answer that question and neither do I
listening to you I can't make an
intelligent guess is because it's just
depends on how his Seasons go and how
well he plays and whether or not he
continues an upward trajectory with his
career that's what it amounts to
otherwise he's out of baseball in two
years right well then you're looking at
the house and you're thinking okay well
if you do if let's say you did sell the
house let's pretend that that you
decided to do what you're saying and you
rent you sell this house what's the down
let's and let's say this ends up being
his last year what's what's the downside
of selling this house letting the money
sit in a high yield or wherever you put
it um for a year and a half but you got
to rent while off seon in the offseason
and what would be the difference between
what you pay in rent and what you're
paying in your
mortgage um our mortgage is about 750 a
month and rent in the area would
probably be a little closer to
1,00 for the months that we rent but
then we'd only have to pay rent for you
know less than half the year so
year-over-year it would be less okay so
what happens do you guys have had to T
the conversation what do you do after
baseball what's he going to do after B
um well I currently have a job that I'll
continue working and he um in the
offseason Works in in town as a coach
for a gym um and he could pick that up
fulltime when he's
done and that's in the town where the
house
is yes sir I'd keep the
house I'd keep the house because there's
a probability there's a high probability
at sometime in the next three or four
years you're going to end up back there
just based on normal professional
careers that's a good point okay um I
hope he is in a smaller probability that
he makes it to the bigs and everything
goes big and you guys are cashing
serious checks and you sell the house
because because you got you a place
that's 80 times bigger and all that I
hope that happens uh but the the vast
majority of sports professionals are
done you know and uh you know at 30
years old and so um
and you're here you're approaching that
so
um yeah if it unless he's in The Bigs he
he's done in three or four years on
average now he might not be he might
play on out five or six years but that
would not be the normal statistical
pattern of the of the
pro athletes that we've worked with okay
so I'm just trying to think this through
in a cold and calculated way not not
really reflecting on your husband's
Talent cuz I have no idea how talented
he is I'm just listening to the story
I'm keeping the house cuz I think you
guys you need it 4 months a year and you
might need it 12 months a year uh when
basball ends for him and so uh and you
start your new life and you're going to
start it in that town and you need yeah
I'm going to keep it I'm going to keep
it in this case and it's not super super
expensive either it's a reasonable
modest home it was an interesting
discussion Sarah I sure hope he does
great me too be cool to have you call me
back someday and go hey you made the
bigs now what do we do with all this
money that'd be great this is the Ramsey
[Music]
show if you're like most people your
home is your most valuable asset and
when you want to make improvements it
can feel like everything costs too much
or takes too long but something as
simple as custom window coverings from
blinds.com can completely change your
space and add value to your home we've
recommended blinds.com for over a decade
so you know you can trust them from
blinds drapes and shutters to motorized
Shades they make it easy and affordable
to upgrade your entire home and their
team is ready to help with everything
from design consultation to measuring
and installation plus there are never
any misleading quotes or hidden fees
everything's backed by their 100%
satisfaction guarantee and shipping is
always free Cy blinds.com is the number
one online retailer of custom window
coverings go to blinds.com and get up to
35% off that's blinds.com to learn more
rules and restrictions May
[Music]
apply
[Applause]
[Music]
Jade wasall Ramsey personality is my
co-host today thank you for joining us
today's question is brought to you by
neighborly your hub for Home Services
here at Ramsey we believe in making home
ownership a blessing
not a burden so we recommend neighborly
Nationwide network of service
professionals to help repair maintain
and improve your home find the help you
need at neighborly
docomo today's question comes from Nate
in Ohio I'm learning about investing and
I want your input on something I hear
how your guy number one can start at
20 I hear how guy number one there you
go can start at 20 years old and invest
$100 a month compared to guy number two
who starts at $3 and invests $200 a
month guy number two will never catch up
because of the compounding interest if I
have debt but also want to invest can't
I do both and benefit from the
compounding interest I have over
$100,000 in debt from college and I do
not believe I can pay that off by the
time I'm 30 but I don't want to wait
until I'm 30 to start investing what do
you think um I love this question and I
you know I wish I what his income was
because I would tell him listen the
average person is getting out of debt in
2 years and let me just add to that cuz
this is just personal this is me talking
even if it took you longer my husband
and I when we paid off our debt it took
us s and a half years to pay off the
debt then we turned around and saved up
our expenses then we turned around and
bought a house we were in our mid-30s
before we started investing and I'm
telling you we're going to be okay and
you're going to be okay too so that's
you're not only going to be okay you're
going to be a millionaire listen Come On
Dave all right let's put that on the
Shelf no it really is it is I mean it's
the math so yeah um here's the
thing
um what you are talking about in your
life Jade what you and Sam did was you
freed up your most powerful wealth
building tool which is your income and
compound interest is very important and
getting started early is the reason we
put those charts out is to motivate you
to get yourself out of debt so you can
started early right but what you lost in
compounding interest during the 7 and
1/2 years of you getting out of debt you
will more than make up that doing that
because you're putting a whole lot more
into Investments instead of freaking
$465,000 of personal debt that's exactly
right and that's what people forget
about they're they're investing up to
the match or they're doing 5 or 10% but
the way we teach you're doing 15% and
Beyond once you get get past payb step
six not to mention I think this is
important to talk about too Dave when
people kind of rearrange the steps right
they're like I don't want to save yet I
don't want to pay off debt I want to
make sure I'm getting that investing in
we find that when you don't do this
thing right when you keep that debt
around right debt equals risk so there's
now more risk in your life there's more
that can go wrong and if you don't take
the time to build up that 3 to six
months of savings when you have an
emergency because you will you will have
to look to your Investments your 401
and all of that to cover your
emergencies and we're seeing that
actually right now more and more more
and more people are borrowing from their
401ks for hardship and they're pulling
out $5,000 and I'm thinking to myself
listen if you had just followed the baby
steps you wouldn't have to pull out
$5,000 you'd have it in baby step three
exactly and and here's the thing if the
theory that you're espousing sir worked
we would find that in the data as we
talk to millionaires
we would find millionaires who are still
paying off their debts but have become
millionaires with the power of compound
interest by starting before they paid
off their debts and we don't find that
and we don't find that we find that the
typical millionaire got the got clear of
the debt and dumped money into
Investments pretty simple it's a very
simple primitive equation but there's
something that happens here it's the um
it's the loss of focus when you're
trying to do two things at once mhm and
you end up sucking at both of them
that's what it amounts to I mean you're
trying to trying to do two different
things at the same time invest and get
out of debt and you're really not good
at either one and so the end result is
not uh the same probability of becoming
a millionaire the same probability of
having a substantial net worth so the
there's um when you have gotten clear of
permanently and never go back to debt
it's a big boost for your wealth
building it's the reason that we've
taught it this way for 30 years and then
the reason has has been borne out in the
actual data as we study the millionaires
so yeah if um in other words at the end
of a 20year story 7 and a half of which
you were getting out of debt yes 12 and
a half of which you will be building an
emergency fund paying buying a house
paying it off and meanwhile dumping 15%
of your income into retirement at the
end of that 20e story you will have more
money yes than you would have had had
you steadily invested a small amount
while you stayed in debt for 17 years
instead of seven that's right not to
mention there's another piece to this
Dave that I mean there's so many pieces
to this when you make the choice to pay
off your debt and say I'm not going into
debt anymore let's pretend you didn't do
that right and you you did this guy's
way you have not said no to debt so
you're continuing to take on debt in
different ways that have the ability to
adversely
affect your net worth and offset what
you might be putting away in retirement
does that make sense cuz you're still
taking out Vehicles you're you're still
utilizing debt in a way that's um
negatively affecting you exactly uh and
here's the
thing here's the problem I just hit me
here's the core issue in this email I
have over $100,000 in debt from college
and I do not believe I can pay that off
boom there it is so the reason you're
wanting to do this is you don't have
hope yeah yeah it's a lack of Hope yeah
it's not that you really think the
numbers are better it's that you don't
think you can do it mhm that's that's
the that's the thing it's a hope thing
here honey it's not a math thing so that
you need to it took me a second it's
down it was down there in that fifth
sentence yeah there was that that that
hopelessness is there it is the power of
Hope is something else when you believe
you can run through a freaking brick
wall man heck yeah there's no you're the
Hulk there's nothing stopping you when
you
believe and uh yeah yeah it's good
that's good Dave it's good good stuff
all right Patrick is with us in San
Diego hey Patrick welcome to the Ramsey
show thank you for taking my call sure
um real quick um 73 years old
um we have a home that we bought in 97
we're in enus uh real close to the beach
uh paid two two 74 oh God it's uh it's
been evaluated uh at
1.9 I would have guessed more wow okay
okay well it's a townhouse for and good
for you so so anyway it's free and clear
you know we paid you know we've been
listening to you for years uh I've been
self a self-employed clinical
psychologist uh retired my wife special
education
teacher um retired uh so what's your
question we have we have no debt we want
to uh we're thinking about selling this
house uh because uh the neighborhood has
gotten uh you know it's crazy at the
beach uh we want to know if we and we
want to downsize um should we buy an
overpriced house in California we're
staying here because our grandkids and
our children are all in California um
that's unfortunate for us cuz we' move
someplace else uh
and should we we're kicking around
should we buy or rent you should buy
because it stabilizes the last 20 25
years of your life I don't care where
you buy but you ought to buy one thing
you can consider um you could buy a
whole lot of Southwest air tickets
that's what I'm thinking for the for the
difference in what you're going to pay
for a house versus if you bought one in
Phoenix
Arizona yeah of course yeah but I'm you
know I I go surfing every morning so you
know it's well you're not you're moving
off the beach you told me yeah well I'm
going to move you know in land with it
mhm but you're Al so you're going to
drive over and surf every morning you
got it m okay all right that's fun good
for you good for you well done yeah I
would buy though the answer to your
question is I would buy so what's he
going to get that's a town that's
smaller than his town home that's less
than 1lion the's getting off the beach
he's getting off the beach going to move
Inland if you move Inland the price goes
down so this is only shot to move down
um I don't know what the rest of your
nest looks like Patrick but if it's
solid I probably wouldn't
sell I'll probably just sit right there
given given what you told me um there's
too many things that you like about this
and only one thing you don't like about
it this is the ramsy
[Music]
show
hey if you're in over your head with
student loans and tired of getting calls
from collection agencies if private
student loan debt is taking away your
financial piece and you don't see any
way out you need why refi they're not a
debt settlement company and they're not
connected to a bank why refi refinances
defaulted private student loans that
other places won't touch and gives you a
custom loan built for you based on your
ability to pay so when you refinance
your private student loan debt with Y
refi you'll have a payment you can
afford with a low fixed interest rate
you couldn't get anywhere else to help
you stick to your budget and work the
debt snowball and you can save thousands
of dollars to learn more about this
custom refinancing option and a lumps
some payoff option you could qualify for
after 24 months call
8442 Ramsey or go to Y rei.com
[Music]
[Applause]
Ramsey
Jade washaw Ramsey personality is my
co-host today thank you for joining us
open phones at
88255 225 Isaac is in Atlanta hi Isaac
how are you good afternoon Dave how you
doing today sir better than we deserve
what's
up um new listener just started
listening about Monday of this week um
and I've known financial situation was
kind of in a mess for a
while um got about $40,000 in debt um 23
of which is a new car I just bought last
Saturday because I needed a vehicle to
get back and forth to
work um trying to get in a situation to
provide for my wife and two kids and
we're expecting a third in May well
congratulations thank you sir 2 buy a
house 2 will be I will be 27 January 1st
almost almost like I've done this before
okay what's the other debt you said you
had
40,000 um it's credit cards and personal
loans what you do for a living sir um I
work two jobs seven days a week I work
five five days a week at a heavy
equipment dealership um in the parks
department and then I work weekends for
Advanced Auto Parts okay all right and
your wife's home with the
kids yes one of them one's in school the
other one they're ages two and five so
so what's your household
income uh about 50 okay all right how
can we best help you
sir um I really just am trying to get
some pointers on how to get this all
down um get the get the credit cards to
zero get rid of them um and and and get
to a point where I can buy a house and
get out of my in-law's house okay that's
a good plan I like that one what's your
wife's car
worth um her
car maybe about three or $4,000 okay
okay well you know you're new to the
show so I'm sure you've heard us talk a
little about the baby steps and I don't
know if you've gone back and been
watched some shows but the first thing
you need is just to get $1,000 set aside
before we start tackling this debt do
you have any money
saved no okay so thing one is you're
you're selling whatever you can get your
hands on you're looking at your wife and
saying listen I know you're at home with
the kids is there any work that you can
pick up that's from home and you guys
are getting resourceful in order to get
this ,000 saved now just something to
light a fire under you most people can
get it in under 30 days so let that be
your goal $1,000 save that's first thing
now after you've got that now we're
working on this debt so what I want you
to do is list them out from smallest to
largest so you said you had the credit
cards you have the personal loan um each
one of those cards list them
individually same thing with the
personal loan what's your smallest
debt uh probably one of the credit cards
it's like $200 or $300 cool I love that
because once you get that $ thousand
saved you're going to be able to knock
that out very quickly in one month right
and then you're going to take all that
money that you would have put on
payments to the next smallest debt right
so while we're doing this we make the
minimum payment on everything but
whatever money you have left that's what
you put on that smallest debt okay so
that's why it's really important $50,000
you know that's a great income but when
you have $40,000 of debt it's tough
right it's it's it's very very tight so
you've got to find ways to get the
income up have you and your wife thought
about any ways that she can contribute
in that area uh we have um we've looked
into it just haven't found anything that
fits just yet yeah take in another kid
well she's not even in her own house
it'd be tough to do that but all right
so um what we've discovered Isaac is the
the more radically you change what
you've been doing the faster you're
going to see positive results moving
away from where you are does that make
sense it does so I'm you're a brand new
listener and I don't know if you can
swallow this that I'm going to throw at
you but I'm going to throw it all at you
anyway because it's what I would want
somebody to do if the roles were
reversed I'd want somebody to tell me to
love me enough to tell me the truth okay
absolutely so the truth is that car you
purchased is a serious dumb butt
decision I realized that it's ridiculous
and when you say I needed a car to get
back and forth to work yeah you needed a
car to get back and forth to work you
needed a bicycle or a $3,000 car to get
back and forth to work you didn't need a
$23,000 car when you live at your
mother-in-laws oh my God you shot
yourself in the foot so I'm going to go
back it was a week ago I'm going over
the dealership and say guys can I give
you
$1,000 to let me out of that deal and
let me just undo
it just see if they'll tear the
paperwork up and take the car
back okay you're not gonna do it it was
painful I could I hear it I told you
this is going to be hard cuz dude it
it's three4 of your problem right now
yeah what's the payment on it
mathematically uh payment is
637 come on man God almighty look that's
your I would listen it's worth $
thousand dollar to get you to get to
undo one of the dumbest things you've
ever done in your life okay and that's
the bad news the good news is you got
the rest of your life to never do
something that dumb again that's awesome
so I've done a lot Dumber things than
what I'm calling this that's why I'm
willing to call it dumb I didn't say
you're dumb I said what you did was Dumb
and it was seriously dumb yeah so it
it's gonna set you back it's GNA keep
you it's gonna add a year and a half to
two years to you getting out of your
mother-in-law's house it ain't worth it
you need a $3,000 car to limp over to
work and the guys in the parts
department make fun of you and besides
that you probably know how to turn a
wrench so you can keep a car running you
just got car fever and fell off the
wagon into the dead gum poop and you
just you got it all over you man so
that's first thing I would do second
thing I would do is what Jade said let's
do anything we can do to get our income
up third thing I'm going to do is we're
going to put scorched Earth on the uh on
the old family here you guys are not a
bunch of spending nuts once we get past
the car but you guys are not doing a
bunch of stupid things you don't have
enough money to do a bunch of stupid
things so I know you're not but even
with that I don't want you eating out
mhm I don't want you going on vacation
and I don't want you spending money on
anything except getting these debts
cleaned up cuz Isaac if you had zero
debt you know how fast you could save
money I do make sense wow that's that's
what I want for you man that's what I
want for you and hey I went bankrupt
when I was 28 with a brand new baby and
a toddler cuz I was stupid on
steroids millions of dollars of debt not
23,000 on a bad car so I got your stupid
beat I got I was way more stupid than
you okay or did way more stupid things
than you did either way you want to look
at it so I'm not picking on you I love
you and I want you to win prove it we're
going to put you into Financial Peace
University which is our 9we class and
we're going to give you the every doll
app with the upgrade so you guys can get
on a hardcore budget you and your wife
start watching those videos
tonight and and before Christmas get
back over to that dealer because you're
still inside of a week and that dealer
may work with you they might have mercy
on you and you give them some amount of
money to to compensate them for the
trouble of tearing up the paperwork and
taking that stupid car back mhm and in
the 14 miles you put on it or whatever
it's been in a week so I that's what I I
man cuz then you just do what Jade said
and you tear through this stuff we're
going to give you all that we're going
to give you all that as a gift for the
for you the new baby I want you out of
your mother-in-law's house I want you
renting something saving up money
getting out of debt having a life and
then work on your career and get your
income up too you don't want to be in
the parts department when you're 38 it's
okay when you're 27 but 11 years from
today Who's Isaac going to be and how's
he going to get there so start aiming at
something let's kick this up in gear cuz
uh part of the problem and it's not the
whole problem but it's part of the
problem is you don't don't make any
money you don't make enough money and
you can go make some more you're it's
not I'm not shaming you I'm just saying
dude if you made $70,000 a year $80,000
a year it changes this equation real
fast you didn't have this $23,000 car it
changes this equation real fast and I'm
about changing the equation fast so you
win look I'm wondering if Mom and Dad
can help out cuz if they're living at
Mom and Dad's house then can Mom and Dad
watch the 2-year-old while Mama goes to
work there you go it's happened before
stranger things have happened that's all
I'm
saying Mama may be at work but I don't
know we'll see yeah I mean there there's
some kind of help going on there I can
guarantee you I'm talking about doing
some radical butt stuff for a short
period of time so I never have to again
live like no one else so later you can
live and give like no one else that's
the plan man hang on Austin's going to
pick up we're going to gift you with
everything Merry Christmas and call back
anytime you need a beauty we're here for
you this is the Ramsey
[Music]
Show hey folks you know that sinking
feeling when you make an offer on a
house you love and then you hear there's
another offer you need the Churchill
Mortgage home buyer Edge super fast
pre-approval and a secured interest rate
plus a $5,000 seller guarantee gives
your offer the best chance of being
accepted the home buyer Edge from Church
Hill gives you an advantage over those
other guys go to Churchill mortgage.com
today to learn
[Music]
more
[Applause]
merry merry Christmas thank you for
being with us Jade washaw Ramsey
personality is my co-host today she is
the author of the brand new quick read
money's not a math problem we've got
that book in the uh Ramsey store we've
also got Rachel Cruz's new book uh I'm
glad for what I have a children's book
about contentment
and it is uh if I do say so myself
fabulous uh Laura G ggos I can't
pronounce Laura's name how do you say it
is that I think that's right anyway she
did the uh she did the uh uh I've met
her a couple times she's a wonderful
lady did the illustrations and this
thing number it's a huge it's a best
seller children's best seller listen I'm
not surprised we sold out we had to get
some more in so they're just coming in
if you want some we can still we can
ship them now uh check the bookstore
George's new book uh Breaking Free from
broke the Ultimate Guide to more money
and less stress George we had to develop
a whole new font for his sarcasm we have
the sarcasm font that we have now U now
no I'm kidding but not much the guy is a
snark King and this you will it's laugh
out loud ripping on the financial
ripoffs uh George is like the ultimate
consumer Advocate uh and funny fun and
you will learn a lot this book is
incredible it comes out in January and
you can pre-order right now for
$20 and guess what you get about $100
worth of stuff when you do the pre-order
on it thank you for doing that folks all
of that stuff and a bunch of other
things are on sale right this second at
the Ramsey store obviously we can't get
it to you by Christmas sorry about that
but um hey it's going to be there and
we'll get it to you and just in time to
start the new year you can do that whoop
who that way we can do it all right
Cliff is with us in Raleigh hi Cliff
welcome to the Ramsey show thank you and
this truly an honor to be on the air
with you guys you you guys are amazing
well thank you how can we
help okay so I'll try to be brief here
um I have been saving I have two kids
that are 19 and 23 my son is a rising
sophomore at college and my daughter is
in graduate school she has one more
semester to go and thanks to you and
some other good advice I've been saving
in a 529 plan since since they were
babies M so I had plenty of money to pay
for most of the tuition um especially
for U my daughter because she got
scholarships as well but anyway but now
there's uh two years left of my co of my
son being in college and one more
semester of my daughter in graduate
school and with my ex I had it set up so
that I paid half like one full year with
mine the other full year was hers but
now she's saying that she doesn't have
the money or she's telling my son that
and so she's trying to force me to use
all of my 529 ST which is totally in my
name and in addition to that my son
who's worked for the past four Summers
he saved about
$10,000 she was trying to force him to
use to drain his entire savings to pay
for this last semester so I feel kind of
bad now we know why she's the
ex very very difficult most people you
can talk to but she didn't it never was
a conversation I was always one way so
she's broke she makes over well she
makes over $100,000 a year yeah she can
still be broke that much that's true
okay so we got two issues one we've got
an obstinate X who's out of control but
that's not the real issue you can't
control the out of control obstinate X
that's why she's the X so what are we
going to what are you going to
do well I I didn't tell her this but I
actually paid for my son's last last
semester fall semester m I I told I told
her that that he used all his money so
that she can't keep coming back to me to
keep paying you know so because if IID
have told her that then she would say oh
well your dad can pay for this semester
coming up you see what I mean yeah yeah
all right so so um we got to manipulate
her because she's a manipulator but uh
but aside from that how much is in the
529 total there's about 28,000 between
both 529 plans not enough to finish the
school for the all all three all three
correct it's not enough corre okay and
then when it's out if she doesn't pay
how are we getting out that's my thing I
don't want them to be in debt she she
can she can make get loans I don't want
them to be in
debt are either is anybody once again
you're trying to control her but I keep
reminding you she's the
ex we can't control her we can only
control what you do so if you think if
you you think telling her that she
better be meet her obligation by the
court that she's supposed to pay because
it's a part of the divorce decree right
no no they're both 18 there's no
agreement this is just this is just you
guys adults so exactly let's work some
of us are adults how how much more are
they going to need to
finish well it'll be about 40,000 okay
so we're 12 Grand off what do you
make right now I make about 70 which I
in the past few years I've I've made
about half that so I'm just now starting
to make a little bit of money and your
son and your son has how
much well he had $10,000 saved which he
still has it but I'm hiding it get all
that I'm trying to figure out what the
reality is not the manipulation of the X
you're spending a lot of energy worrying
about her I'm trying to get you to quit
doing that yeah because if you stop you
he's got 10 she you got 28 that's 38 you
need 40 you you're done you're done it's
not even a problem you're done cuz
here's the thing you pretty much know I
know and I've only been talking to you
for about 80 Seconds that she's not
going to
pay she's not going to do it
do so I just need to get my son to drain
his savings is she gonna do
it I don't I don't know what she's going
to do I really don't and I and hold on a
sec cuz you're saying it's not bad if
you're like son's going to drain his
savings he's paying for his education
and that's good if he's contributing a
little bit it's he shouldn't have to
drain it if his mother wasn't a twerp
but that's the deal that's besides the
point at this point like like you said
they can't control her um right and I
don't I I would make a run at
manipulating her and just saying it's
your turn but I mean i' make a run at it
but you need to be prepared to start
writing checks cuz I don't think this
chick's coming through I I did send her
a certified letter about a month ago
before I called you guys and laid out
kind of basically what I'm telling you
guys was a one page very businesslike
here's what I've paid year half is there
you know and I said that my son is
basically broke now based on her plan so
that's that's all I've done so is she
GNA pay then I don't I really don't know
I don't I hope so I I don't I don't have
much
hope I think she has I think she has
displayed her colors and they are very
clear yeah but um but you know so what I
would do is make a run at getting her to
pay but be mathematically and
emotionally prepared to start writing
the checks out of the 28 and out of the
10 okay that's helpful that's painful
but that is helpful well something you
listen here's something the other option
is your kid goes in debt cuz his wife
cuz his mother's an
idiot basically and no that's not okay
yeah not when he's got 10 and you got 28
and you need 40 to finish you can do it
he can do it yall can pull this off it's
not okay so we're not going to leave the
third the option of him going in debt
cuz his mother goofed up is not on the
plan so he doesn't have to drain his
savings no he uses his savings like Jade
said it's called an investment in your
education you're paying for college well
that's okay I paid for part of my
college most of it as a matter of fact I
think almost almost all of it but yeah
there you go it's like yeah and I worked
all the time you start paying for
college you'll be more engaged than
you've ever been because you know where
your money is going yeah there's that
too so yeah I Cliff I think you know
you're looking for justice and I don't
blame you for that but I don't think
Justice is going to occur here Justice
is she stands up and goes oh I'm his mom
I should keep my word I should pay my
half I'm going to be a grown-up and
adult and take care of my part of the
bargain I'm going to have integrity but
nothing you described about this woman
indicates she's actually going to do
that um if you have any hope of that you
have more hope than I do cuz everything
you described about her describ someone
that's not going to follow through on
this so she might but and again I'd give
it a shot at yeah jacking her up and
getting her to do it I don't care if
she's mad I mean let's get her going
let's get her going is like that woman I
can tell that woman is drives him crazy
and when she gets him wound up he'll
just he's just spinning his wheels
trying to figure out why won't she do
this why yeah yeah that she she's the ex
for a reason x x x x stay SA far away XX
XXX you know there's a reason just just
get distance distance if we could put up
with it crazy we'd still be married
hello right this is the Ramsey
[Music]
Show
oh
[Music]
live from the headquarters of ramsy
solutions it's the ramsy show where we
help people build wealth do work that
they love and create actual amazing
relationships I'm Dave Ramsey your host
Jade washaw Ramsey personality and uh
author of the new quick read money's not
a math problem she's my co-host today at
open phones at
88255 225 Mary Merry Christmas thank you
for being with us we're so glad you're
here Megan is with us Megan is in
Louisville Kentucky Hi Megan welcome to
the Ramsey Show hi thank you so much for
having me I'm in the parking lot of the
dry cleaners I just picked up my wedding
dress awesome Y how
fun thank you I'm getting married on the
1 of January and I'm so excited yay you
should be
congratulations thank you so much um so
my fiance is amazing he's incredible but
um he's not that great with money which
is why I'm
calling sorry so um we've been together
for a while and um over the course of
the last maybe year um he revealed that
he's in a lot of credit card debt um
about $588,000
worth yeah um so in February of this
year I actually took out a home equity
loan um at prime rate so what is that
8.5 I think well wait a second you said
he's not that great with money you're
taking out helocs what are you taking
out a helck for yeah I mean I knew where
we were going I knew we were forever and
I knew I wanted to just nip this in the
bud so he cut up his credit card and we
put all of his money um we Consolidated
all of his credit card debt into a HELOC
and he's been making steady payments
since then to me to pay on that Lord
Jesus okay okay so um he commits to
about $1,000 a month to paying that off
and um we're predicting about a four and
a half year to five year payoff of all
no no no what do you
make oh I only make $660,000 year and he
makes 120 okay so you make $180,000 you
have $58,000 in debt we are not waiting
six freaking years you're doing this
next
year okay okay we we have made some
mistakes he yeah had a bunch of credit
card debt and was overspending
apparently he has stopped that I hope it
sounds like you made a mistake of
financing someone that you weren't
married to's debt that you're getting
ready to fix that in about a week thank
you God so you'll be safe at that point
and uh we don't want to spoil the
wedding with too much of this talk but
as soon as you guys get home from the
honeymoon now it's we have $558,000 in
debt and we need to pay that off with
our $180,000 income as fast as we can
and that means we ain't doing nothing
till we get this mess cleaned up do you
guys have any either one of you have any
money
yeah so I actually have about $55,000 in
stocks that I got as um bonus from a job
I previously had that I've never touched
so the time to touch it after after
you're
married cash that out and pay this
off great okay that's what I was hoping
you were gonna say but I wasn't sure if
that's a wise decision so it's a
wonderfully wise decision now here's the
trick the two of you from uh This Day
Forward are going going to lock arms and
not borrow money and be on a budget
together and communicate a lot more
about money than you had
been yes in other words if his spending
stays above his
income and the credit cards grow back
because the habits didn't
change then the advice we just gave you
might not have been smart
agreed yes that makes sense did I hear
you say it's a scary
topic yes it's it's a little
nerve-wracking to to uh confront his you
know weak links you know the fact that
Hees like spend a lot of money it's you
too because he he did rack up that
credit card debt but listen it was not a
smart choice to roll it into a HELOC I'm
not going to lie about that so I think
you both have something some things to
learn here I think we should give them
Financial Peace University yeah if we
give you the class will you go through
it together so you got a book to work
from I would love for him to have those
resources and for me to be a part of
that as well I think that would be
amazing let me help you that's not how
it works okay he doesn't need the
resources we need to go through the
class together so we are doing this
stuff together not not Dave's going to
school him
up I I understand I completely
understand I'm just listening to your
verbiage kiddo so yeah okay you hang on
we're going to give this to you as a
wedding gift and a Christmas present
since we Abus you right before your
wedding I we just yelled at her right
before the wedding it's just but she's
picking up her wedding dress calls
cleaners and we yell at her so nobody
yelled at her we love her we want her to
win true but we kept I kept telling her
she was just as as well she is she is
they both I won say the s word they both
did silly things a silly the SW word oh
my gosh they both did stupid things all
right there we go come on own it there
we go it's okay we love her and she's
going to win she she's smart she makes
good money he makes good money if but
listen the thing is what we want for you
this is the number one money and money
issues are the number one stress point
in marriage Megan and you're getting
married so we want you guys to have real
clean open honest dialogue around this
both of you uh we don't want touchy
subject we don't want you you know
you're not shaming him uh we both are
looking at this and saying okay from
this point forward we're not using
credit cards from this point forward
we're going to agree on a budget and
we're going to stick to the budget that
we both agreed to it's a it's a marital
contract uh from this point forward
we're going to save up and pay cash for
things cuz you're dumping
$60,000 of money that you brought into
the marriage against his mistakes M yeah
and so the two of you together need
assurances that the two of you together
are going to move forward in very clean
stuff the old wedding vows most people
know in sickness and in health for rich
or for poor in sickness and in health
the old wedding vows in the book of
common prayers say unto thee all my
worldly Goods I pledge oo and so that
indicates this Unity this Oneness in the
marriage where we're sharing
everything not your debt my debt not
your checking account my checking
account not your income my income it's
our hour hour hour hour hour when you
get married you're a French we we we
it's ours okay that's what you're doing
and there's a Oneness to that and by the
way not only is that a beautiful and
romantic and wonderful marriage thing
where the communication is very high and
the quality of the relationship is very
high the uh interesting part also is the
data tells us from studying millionaires
that it increases the probability of you
becoming wealthy vastly the number of
people that become wealthy while
dragging a misbehaving spouse is almost
zero it's almost zero so this this idea
that you work together it's like we're
going to do this together we're going to
raise kids together when you when you
argue about what how to treat you know
how to to make the kids behave the kids
are the only ones that lose you know
when you argue about how to make the
money behave the money loses you know so
getting on that same page is a big deal
and that's not just aimed at Megan
that's aimed at all of you out there
this time of year some of you are home
for Christmas you got a little time on
your hands you need to sit down with
each other and go hey this is what's
going on it this will be some confession
is good for the soul time for some of
you some of you got to come clean on I'm
kind of ashamed I've been doing this I'm
I'm really been doing some stuff I don't
like and I know you're not going to like
it and I don't even want to talk about
it but we're going to talk about it
that's the that you need to do some of
that throughing the holidays some of you
but hang on Austin I'll get you signed
up Jay just gave her Financial Peace
University and every dollar the world's
best budgeting app this is the Ramsey
[Music]
Show
hey guys I've told you before about
Christian Healthcare Ministries a health
cost sharing Ministry but listen to
Jenna a chm member she says one of my
biggest concerns about entrepreneurship
and motherhood was figuring out how to
take care of our health expenses but we
have found a solution that works for us
in an incredible way she loves that with
chm she can help other families who need
it and receive help back when her own
family has an eligible medical event chm
has been a godsend for Jenna that's her
chm story and it could be yours learn
more and join at chministries.org
[Music]
budget
Jade washaw Ramsey personality is my
co-host today Sam is in De Mo Iowa Hi
Sam welcome to the Ramsey
Show hey guys appreciate you having me
on sure what's
up hey uh so just a quick kind of
background a wife and I got married uh
end of July um and around that time was
when we first kind of discovered your
guys' show and I've been listening to it
ever since um we've been working our way
through financial piece um have paid off
about 21 Grand of debt since then good
for you are going thank you yeah things
going really well for us had a lot of
debt going into the marriage um but
right now uh kind of the question I have
is our biggest debt is a truck that I
bought about a year ago that I
definitely shouldn't have um safe to say
it was before I had heard of you guys
and kind of how you guys went about
things with that um no I need to sell it
um but my biggest issue right now is I
have it out on the private sell market
and it's still around or looking at 33
to 36 um and we owe 365 on it um my
biggest issue right now is I'm having a
lot of trouble selling it it's been out
probably for about three or four months
I've been putting it on all the you know
Marketplace um eBay and all that stuff
what what is your household
income um right around 100K okay so you
can pay the payment this just
accelerates the get out of debt plan and
it um is kind of the admission that you
made a mistake when you bought it and
that's the reason we're getting rid of
it so my point is there's no Panic it's
okay if it takes a little while don't
give the truck
away okay you don't have to you don't
have to give it away yeah because you'd
have to give it away if we were about to
be
repoed right right yeah right now the
dealership is they're offering from 28
to 29 so that put us about six grand
under yeah so it's probably not worth 36
cuz you're not getting nibbles at that
it's probably worth
33 yeah that's kind of what I'm hoping
to get Private Sales 3 334 and to make
up the difference on the loan because
right now the payment each month is
about 600 a month yeah I think what have
you got it listed
at um right now I have it listed at on
Marketplace and on Craig is about 335
okay that's not bad I think you'll
probably get some nibbles unless
somebody was buying for a Christmas
present you're not getting anything in
December on it so it's going to be it's
going to be January and you're in De Mo
in January somebody's going to need a
truck okay I mean it's okay but don't
panic I mean if it takes five more
months don't don't get don't sell it for
28 right just drive it just drive it and
pay the
payment okay all right that seems simple
enough yeah cuz you're not panicking see
you don't have to you don't you know
like we don't we don't disc count a
house 50,000 bucks to sell it unless we
really have to sell the
house yeah that makes sense it's the
same thing here my yeah yeah my view is
like you said just kind of accelerate
their process a little bit and
everything but yeah I want you to I want
you to sell it I want you to be
realistic in your pricing so it sells
but I don't want you to give it
away okay yeah that makes sense so just
give yourself some permission for it to
take a little while cuz it's a big old
truck I mean you know selling selling
the 20 trucks a lot different selling a
$40,000 truck that's true it's a it's a
lot different Marketplace for that so um
and you know the economy's bouncing
around interest rates are bouncing
around people are deciding whether
they're sitting on the bench or whether
they're coming into the game you know
they're jumping back and forth on real
estate on car purchases everything else
it's not been a good season for car
dealers this last fall has not been like
car dealer Heaven how long should he sit
on it at that price point how how long
would you sit on
the thing
is what your what the only reason we're
going to adjust the prices is that we're
admitting that it's really not worth
that but we're not adjusting the price
to motivate a buyer MH that's the
difference okay so if the truck's
evidently not worth 36 you got almost no
activity in three months so the range
was 33 to 36 so let's get it on down to
33 and then you know we'll keep bumping
it down a little bit at a time just a
little bit at because we're trying to
find the price we're trying to find the
actual value the market we're not trying
to bring people to the table to get a
deal right that's different M and uh so
I it might take four or five months it
really might Kyle Is With Us in
Greensboro North Carolina hi Kyle
welcome to the Ramsey show Merry
Christmas yes sir I was wondering how to
navigate staying debt free while also
having no
credit well that's great it's kind of
the same thing isn't
it yeah yeah absolutely um what are you
trying to do
specifically so um I I was going to
college in Asheville and I moved back in
with my parents and and you know I'm not
going to live with my parents forever So
eventually I have to be able to buy home
and all that fun sort of stuff how old
are
you I'm 23 years old okay what do you do
for a
living uh so I work for my dad's
construction company is a they call me a
gopher when they ask me to go for them
to do this and go for me
I've done that myself it's not a bad job
uh What uh so what do you
make I I make anywhere so I'm also a
Salesman so um I make anywhere between
35 and 40 depending on um you know how
productive the year is and you don't
have any debt and you you've decided
you're not borrowing money
anymore yes ma'am I I've never borrowed
any money if I if I could help it I'd lo
my truck in cash and yeah so if you move
out if you move out you make $40,000 and
GE and get an apartment what's wrong
with
that well so I've always you know I
rented an apartment when I was going to
college in Asheville and it was it was
so much money on something that was that
what felt temporary to me well it is
temporary yeah and I living with your
mom oh yes yes sir absolutely but I mean
I I give them $150 for groceries in a
month here and so I'm just saving up as
much money as I possibly can while I'm
here um I just feel kind of throwing
away the, or $1,500 a
month well it's not it's not 1,000 or500
to start with in Greensboro North
Carolina so you can find a one bedroom a
lot cheaper than that or get a get a
roommate and you'll be a lot cheaper
than that uh and there's no rush but the
next phase of your life is to be to be
running your own household be in control
of your own house something happens
inside your brain when you have to buy
your own bread and wash your own
towels okay oh you like I said I mean
yes sir yeah so I I want you to go do
that sometime in the next six months I
want you to find a place to and then and
then I'm going to just start building up
cash and there is no uh back to your
original question we picked up Kyle uh
there is no mandate that you go in that
you use debt there is no mandate that
you have credit uh as a matter of fact
the people that are the wealthiest are
the ones that don't and so staying away
from payments like you have wisely done
you paid cash for a car I kind of think
you're a cheap skate I like you you
don't want to spend money on rent you
you know you it's cheaper to live at
home you like piling up the money you
didn't want a car payment you saved up
and paid for a truck I like that that's
all good wise decision making I think
you're thinking the right way and so
just continue on down that path don't
let some of your uh crazy friends or
cousins or something convince you that
you need to go get credit or go get a
credit card or go get payments you don't
uh those that don't are the ones with
the most money because they don't give
Banks money
when you quit handing Banks money you
have some money as long as you make some
and you know how to work and make money
if you're in the construction business
it's interesting how with this
house this housing market I just think
it's all the time how people are on such
far extremes it's like you know renting
is horrible and you're throwing your
money down the drain and you never rent
and then over here is Grant Cardone says
never buy a house and d and I'm like
guys why can't it just be in the middle
your rent for a little while until you
can afford to buy a home and then you
buy a home like that's just I mean it it
makes sense and it's logical when you
rent it's not for life it's not forever
yes it's is patience at different stages
of your life there are there are times
that you rent for a reason and it's not
um it's not a way of life it's not a
long-term thing but owning a home is
wise is a longterm play is a part of
your financial thing so you know people
yelling and screaming on Tik tock
these extremities it doesn't have to be
like that who cares what they say it's
not they're not it's not they're not
real people that's just avatars I mean
well Avatar they're avatars walking
they're humans walking around acting
like avatars okay you go you go they're
just they're just extreme crazy and so
just use some common sense think about
your grandma you know think about how
this makes sense and yeah when you first
get married or you're first starting out
of your mom and dad's house renting
something is normal it takes you a
little while to get your Fe on the
ground save up some money buy your first
house there's nothing wrong with that
nothing nothing out of line about that
and live but living at home to your 28
and your mama doing your laundry no you
need to get out on your own young man
young lady you need to get out there and
be like a grownup and stuff hey let me
just tell you an eagle that fails to
leave the nest is eventually known as a
turkey this is the ramsy
[Music]
show
[Applause]
[Music]
Jade washaw Ramsey personality is my
co-host today Merry Christmas thank you
for being with us the phone number Isle
88255 225 Dina is in Paulie's Island
South Carolina hi Dina how are you or
Dena I'm sorry hi hi Dave yeah it's Dena
Merry Christmas to you and your team and
thank you so much for having me on I've
been listening for a lot of years um I
just want to tell you that um I
certainly have been trained by my
parents to um pay off my home and that's
what I plan to do um this coming August
y about yeah I know oh thank you we owe
about 41,000 and what I I'm a school
teacher so what I plan to do is I have a
tax sheltered annuity that I've had
since
1995 and there's not a lot in there but
it's roughly around 28,000 so I was
going to use that to pay off my house
okay in August great okay and I've been
double thank you and I've been doubling
up on the payments to get it all cleared
out but here's my dilemma or I have
plans I have a home that's about 24
years old and it is in need of like
Renovations as far as it needs probably
um the siding removed and put new siding
up or fiber cement or something like
that is what I really want to do and
also possibly put um a little sun room
on the back of the house and we have no
debt my husband and I we drive very old
cars um we don't need out a lot so we
kind of want to do something you know to
the to the house like that but I'm kind
kind of scared as far as I want to
retire at
60 um but I don't know if I can swing
all this and without I don't know if I
have to get a HELOC or if I could use I
know you're not gonna pay off that house
and then borrow against it again right I
don't want to do that you're not gonna
do that don't even say it out loud yeah
it's not even an option you've been
listening to this show you knew not to
say that here I know um but I know but
think about what you really say I mean
think what what's your household
income our household income is um 158
okay
$158,000 and you don't have a payment in
the world starting in August how much is
the sighting get a bid how much is the
sun room get a bid save and do one then
save and do the
other okay if you can save to pay off a
house you can save to do these
improvements it's just G to take a
little
time right well what I was going to do
is if I'm if I had the house paid off um
this August I'll be 59 and a half and
then like I would still work this school
year so I could sock all that money away
and at least do one of the improvements
and pay cash work two work two more
years who cares you're just a baby work
two more years yeah you don't have to
retire one year for the sun room one
year for the sighting you make 158,000
as long as you're working I didn't get
the quitting work part until just now
but yeah work a little bit more who
cares
well she's like I care D I'm pretty
tired you have to choose okay you got
you got a choice do you want to flor a
room or do you want to work a year
you're right no I get okay I got another
question real quick can I I don't have
any we don't have any
airs can I do a reverse mortgage what
are you saying well where where is that
woman that called and said that she
listened to the
show where did you do with her
you didn't put her in the closet and
lock her up did you I think you're play
you're playing games with us are you
playing I'm exploring options don't
explore those I can I can still it's
Christmas we're supposed to be nice
you're making it hard you're turning us
into Grinch and Scrooge and everybody
else okay okay you know the answer all
right so here's the deal here's the deal
get the prices on the
stuff and then sit down and look at that
versus your income consider you have no
payments starting in
August okay and really I mean it's
probably uh how many square feet is your
home it's roughly 1,800 okay all right
so $20,000 does a
sighting yeah I hope so yeah yeah yeah
and you can have you can have you can
have $20,000 do the sighting by this
time next year what what are you putting
towards your mortgage right now let's
let's look at this what are you putting
towards the Mortage mortgage you said
you're making double payments what is
that um I paid 3,360 a month okay that's
$36,000 a
year yeah so at 20,000 it leaves you
20,000 uh by this time next year at
Christmas you should be able to put
siding on the house in cash I should
yeah you're right and then by and then
by this time next summer you'll have a
Florida
room six more months you got a Florida
room and and and then then you're done
just just just plan it out the problem
is you're you've got these things
floating around with no actual numbers
attached to them and they're floating
around in your brain in your emotions
rather than in your math brain use your
math brain and it'll calm you
down okay go get go get some actual bids
and timeline this out in your actual
budget like I just did and say okay
based on being done in August oh wait a
minute we could be be done in July or
June oh wait well then oh my by February
we've got a sun oh okay you know and you
start when you actually get the actual
bids and get two or three bids so that
you're getting good
contractors and um and you know quit
entertaining these crazy butt ideas that
you know are crazy butt yeah oh God
reverse mortgage you've got to be
kidding me but there is something about
that that's worth speaking about you
know you you make it all the way through
baby step 6 you pay off your mortgage
there is still going to be things that
come up that you have to save and
possibly sacrifice in order to have it
doesn't take away do you know what I'm
saying like you don't you never have
enough money to not watch your money
exactly like there's no such thing
there's going to be something you want
to do and you're going to have to pull
the P strings in Tighter and you're
going to have to decide okay what do I
want to what do I want to sacrifice or
trade in order to get that over time
that part never goes away it's it just
may not be to the extremes that it once
was right yeah being debt-free doesn't
make it you know where you have no
boundaries you do anything you want to
do it just makes it just frees up the
vast majority of your income when you
focus it with great intentionality to do
the next thing John is in Philadelphia
hey John how are you hey Mr Ramsey M War
hi big fan Merry Christmas Merry
Christmas how can we help I have a uh a
whole life insurance policy I'm sorry I
know you hate uh my mother took it out
me when I was a baby how sweet and uh it
is now a cash value of about $133,000
and a death benefit of about
$21,000 that's what you get when you get
one as a baby wow I'm sorry it was only
worth 5,000 as a baby it accumulated
over the years uh what's your opinion on
what I should do with that cash at
tomorrow really wow put the 13,000 in
something that'll actually grow okay
yeah you you're you've been making one
or 2% your whole life on this thing you
got $133,000 sitting in a horrible
product making almost no money the net
is cuz by the way they're going to keep
the 13,000 if you die and write a check
for 21 so you actually don't have 21 in
Insurance what you actually have is a
eight in
Insurance okay 21 minus 13 so you put
the 13 in your pocket if you need some
life insurance go get some life
insurance the proper amount in term to
cover your kids your mama your family
your wife whatever okay but you you
don't this is a joke it's a a it's a
super small policy uh B it's a horrible
rate of return see when you die they're
going to keep the $133,000 it's just you
need to get it out of there before you
die quickly like this week go ahead and
turn it in and get your money and put
the money in a good investment or pay it
on wherever you are in the baby steps
but yeah this is
um
uh I don't know if we'll ever get rid of
all of those all the whole life plans
yeah but I mean they did I mean he's
he's probably I'm gonna guess and say
he's 30 or 40 years old okay so that was
that was sold 25 30 years ago but most
people now know that that's horrible
product the vast majority of the public
has a knowledge base that says whole
life life insurance universal life sucks
it's horrible it's the payday lender of
the middle class most people know that
so people aren't running around buying
$5,000 policies on their babies anymore
much I mean Gerber's still selling still
sell them Gerber when you're in the
hospital which just blows my mind Gerber
okay let's get this straight you're
buying Financial investment in
investment programs for your children
from a baby food company have you lost
your
mind I mean seriously that's just
straight up it's like I'm going to the
transmission store to buy cereal
unbelievable this is the Ramsey
Show
[Music]
he
Jade wasall Ramsey personality is my
co-host today open phones atle
8825 5225 Merry Christmas Janice is with
us in Atlantic City New Jersey hi Janice
how are you I'm well thank you thank you
so much for taking my call um my husband
and I have been married for 7 years I'm
59 years old he's 6 1 years old we have
four children a 7year old a 9ye old 25y
old and 26 year old the older two are
children from my husband's first
marriage um my husband took out Parent
Plus loans for the two older children
that amount to about 130,000 oh my God
and now we're in the process of trying
to figure out how to pay that back while
trying to make sure we provide for our
younger children and look towards
retirement um we've got a couple options
that I don't really
like um one of which is we sold our main
home um because I was temporarily in an
assignment and we weren't in the house
and we could use the proceeds from that
sale sale of the home to pay off the
loan but that would make us without a
real home we have a second home that
we're currently living in um that he
would prefer if we sold a second home um
but I I don't feel like you know some of
this is being paid off of money that I
saved or saved to be able to pay for the
second home so one I want to know what
my obligation is and two we're looking
for the best option of how to pay off
these loans this is this is interesting
your your obligation is the loans get
paid you married a guy who borrowed
$130,000 send his kids to school and so
that's what you married and so the two
of you got to clean it's blocking the
the future as you said of your younger
kids and uh and the future of the two of
you so you got to clean it up so what
are the proceeds from the sale of the
other house how much money have you got
um it's now 230 it was 280 but now it's
230 and you got 130 and Parent PLUS yes
okay so now you got 100 what else you
got in
debt that's it our cars are paid off um
our the mortgage paid off and the house
that you're living in is you all don't
want to live
there it is my opinion that we should
live here and save money and pay off the
loan um my husband would prefer not to
it's close to the beach there's nothing
else around um he doesn't think he would
be happy to live in this home
okay what is the home that you're living
in
worth um we paid 205 for it it's
probably maybe it's that was three years
ago it's probably maybe 240 250 by now
and what do you owe on it nothing oh
good okay so if you had if you sold that
and you had 100,000 left over after
paying off the loans you'd have 350 can
you go buy something for 350 that you
both
like probably um you know it would be
tough and I say that but you know I feel
as I've gotten older in life that I I
cannot um live in a a a smaller smaller
home it would be hard to do but the home
that you're currently living in is not
smaller
smaller it has three bedrooms and two
and a half baths it is a town home our
kids have a place to play um so it has
all of the I think the Necessities I
would take something like this so he do
the only the only issue is your husband
doesn't want to live there he really
just preferred not to live in this area
because he doesn't feel he would have
enough things to do and um
yeah okay well here's the thing what
would I do if I woke up in your shoes
all right I would write a check today
and pay off the student loans that's
done okay now you got $100,000 in the
bank and you got a $250,000 paid for
house then the two of you you and your
husband need to sit down together and
what what I'm now hearing is is that you
are not in agreement on where you want
to
live you're fine with you're fine with
where you are he's not you're not fine
with where
350,000 with these two sources would
take you but you're perfectly find in
this $250,000 s you know house so uh
somewhere in there you guys got to find
something that the two that the four of
you can live in that you pay cash for
that is 350 or under and then you're set
up to move into retirement well but you
got no debt at that point you got your
income house was paid off that's where I
want you to end up you don't go out take
take out a debt you don't go out and
take out a mortgage cuz that's the same
thing as borrowing on your house to pay
off student loans then we're not doing
that you got $100,000 plus this and you
got to hold an emergency fund out of
course if you don't have that separate
already um and then you guys need to be
investing in your retirement once you
get the house purchase but you know you
guys need to talk about okay we have
$350,000 to deal with to uh I'm
comfortable here you're not so where is
it that we can talk about going that
both of us are going to be okay this 3
and
under and y'all start looking and
talking about that and maybe that shuts
him up and you stay where you are or
maybe that you find something that fits
that and does both okay I I'm currently
building a home in a neighborhood uh I
personally would have built a home on my
farm but my wife wouldn't live there so
I would be by myself and so these are
compromises you make when you're married
and so we're building a house where
Sharon wants to build a house um um and
I'll be okay with it I'm okay with it
but it's not my first choice it's my B
Choice yeah right and so you do that
sometimes and you guys got to look at
that so is this his b choice but it's
okay uh but there's not a choice in this
discussion that's 500,000 and you go in
debt that's not a choice so you guys I
I'd write a check today pay off these
debts and um the two of you then sit
down and say we got 350,000 how are we
going to live out the rest of our life
real estate wise I'm wondering if
there's a world where the step kids are
contributing to those student loans at
all it depends on what they set up from
the beginning I guess yeah I mean
they're they're not legally liable
they're not legally but a lot of times
they promise they sign them yeah because
the the the kid can't sign anymore I I'm
I'm kind of guessing there's zero chance
of that just the way the conversation
went but I I was a guess I I went with
the Assumption they weren't contributing
and they're not liable they're not no
it's in the name and you know Janice is
like what's my obligation you're
freaking an obligation you married a guy
borrowed 13,000 you're going to pay it
that's your obligation so uh yeah that's
when you hear words like that that's
when you know you got to yeah it's not
you have to pay it even though it was
you that's what Parent PLUS is that's
why it sucks so bad parent plus should
be called parent
minus but it's not Brandon is in
Philadelphia hi Brandon how are you I'm
good how are you sir better than I
deserve what's
up um so basically I started a new job
and the new job offers a 401k and my old
job offered a simple IRA and I'm not
allowed to transfer my funds from the
simple IRA into 401K so I'm just not
sure what to do with the money that's in
the simple IRA
account uh the regulations allow you to
but maybe your 401k doesn't but I
wouldn't do it anyway so it doesn't
matter you simply roll it to an IRA just
get with a smart Vestor Pro and sit down
and open an IRA and do a direct transfer
rollover is it a Roth or is it a
traditional the simple from what I know
is it's called the simple IR no I mean
yeah but they make simple Roth and they
make simple
regular H so it's probably probably a
traditional whatever it is you just do
an IRA that's the same if it's a Roth
you roll it to an IRA Roth if it's not
you roll it to an IRA traditional either
one's fine and you just and you set it
up how much money is in it uh I think
around 12 Grand oh not a ton okay we
pick you out a couple pick you out a
couple of good growth stock mutual funds
and drop it in there roll it over a
direct transfer means it goes straight
from them to the mutual fund company
with the smart Vestor Pro you don't
touch the check and 100% of the money
moves and a zero tax due okay all right
it's very easy to do it's a you know six
or seven pieces of paper sit down though
it's a good experience for you to pick
out a good smartvestor Pro click ramsy
solutions.com find the people we endorse
in those areas and they'll sit down with
you
and um jade you've done it I've done it
right I've done it yeah it's worth it
they help you through it yeah because if
you cash it out I mean they're going to
take a government's going to take half
of it exactly because you you would be
doing so before retirement and you don't
want that so when you do it as a
transfer no it never it never leaves the
electronic space yeah never never leave
never leaves the uh the matx the warmth
of the U retirement covering there you
go it goes from one retirement covering
to another directly a direct transfer
rollover goes straight from the old
company to the new account doesn't come
to your house see if they send it to you
they have to withhold 20% on it and yet
you've got to put 100% in so you're not
going to have but about 10,000 bucks and
you got to put 12 in so you that's why
you do a direct transfer and the 20%
withholding is not enough to cover the
problem that you're going to create so
it's a weird weird dichotomy so the
direct transfer and sit down with a
smartv pro they'll show you how to do it
good question man Merry Christmas that
puts us our the Ramsey Show in the
[Music]
books
live from the headquarters of ramsy
solution it's the Ramsey show where we
help people build wealth do work that
they love and create actual amazing
relationships Jade washaw Ramsey
personality host of well host of the
author of the new book Math's not a
money problem a 76 page quick read a um
well it's a major major chapter and
you'll be done yeah that fast and you'll
learn a lot about life and about money
she's my co-host today the phone number
here is
88255 225 as we draw near to the end of
our live broadcast for the calendar year
update on the show for the year we did
242 shows this year live ones we've
talked to over 3,200 people on the air
doing this show this year we did 184
debt free screams totaling 36
m596 447
uh that's a ton so um we generally have
about $40 million $5 or $40 million
worth of debt free screams a year on the
debt free stage um and we've done that
for many many years so if you want to
add that up that's like a
lot um I'm guessing we're over a billion
got in debt free screams alone not
counting what everybody else did off
camera off camera off mic but uh pretty
incredible and what a great year what a
wonderful year we're celebrating around
here uh We've yesterday hit number one
on Apple podcast uh so it's a big deal
for us thank you and um literally thank
you cuz you guys out there did that I
mean you've been subscribing and sharing
and leaving five-star reviews thank you
for that that makes a huge difference
and we really do appreciate you uh and
that way when somebody's sitting around
during the holidays bored and they just
open up their phone and go I'm going to
look at a podcast well there what's this
number one I wonder what this thing is
well they'll just stumble their little
butt into here and learn about money and
life who knew and uh that's how that
works it's a great promotional item and
we appreciate it listen beating those
True Crime podcasts is a big deal cuz
that is huge well they have a
disadvantage because there's a bunch of
them yeah well there's only one of us
that's true but there's other Money
podcasts yeah I know but there no I
don't think there's any the top 10 yes
exactly I mean there's some news stuff
and the crime stuff and my buddy
huberman that's a great podcast I love
his and um I mean there's a few others
that bump in and out of there and my
wife listen and Blake Thompson our
producer on the on the network do a lot
of those True Crime do you do those I
can't I can't I need to sleep at night
Dave like that's like my worst
nightmares I can't be listening to that
I I I yeah I I can't the other thing I'm
I am such a wuss I can't go to horror
movies me either I won't I have never
gone to horror movies in my life I get
scared I do too and I don't like being
scared and I feel sorry the pants off of
me yeah I don't get it I just I'm a I'm
a wuss I don't I can't do it no well
Merry Christmas to you America Triple 8
5225 Lindsay's with us in Waco Texas hi
Lindsay how are you I'm good how are
y'all better than we deserve what's
up so I'm in a little bit of a pickle my
husband wants to buy a brand new St by
side so let me give you some
context yesterday we closed in our house
um we will take home a little over
33,000 on it you sold your house paid
for you sold your house house okay you
got 33 $30,000 in your pocket okay yes
our current house that we're living in
our new house is paid for cool um we're
I convinced them to take 29,000 of that
and pay off his
truck and now he wants to go buy a brand
new stop outside and I'm like but we
have other things I need to pay for and
I keep telling him no and he keeps
saying I we we have money now I'm like
we don't we don't have money well not if
he spends it on a side by side you don't
have any money no I don't have money to
thr the rest let me stop a second you
don't have the money to buy a side by
side right no okay so he's talking
about this is the same man that
yesterday paid off his truck and now he
wants to go back in debt so he's not
really on the get out of debt plan he's
just kind of going along when you tell
him to do something until he want to do
it yeah yeah so this is not a money
problem this is a husband
problem I agree okay so how old are you
two uh we just both turned 37 on Sunday
and Tuesday this week yeah what's he do
for a living He is um a heavy equipment
mechanic by trade but he just got into
inside sales which promoted him like
upgraded him on his hourly w
yeah but he's a he's a mechanic by trade
what do you do he's me I'm an
occupational therapist assistant we I
gross um and what other debts do you
have now that his truck is paid
off I have we have a camper that we
bought and we do use it we use it like
almost I don't care what are the debts
have you got I know you don't care um I
have a camper and student loans that's
it how much is a camper
debt UH 60
$60,000
yes that wasn't of my choice either yes
it was you're a grownup and you live
there and you signed the papers I didn't
sign anything how is he buying this like
when this H when this goes down what
takes place he goes over to the dealer
on his own signs for it and says honey
look I bought us a camper is that what
happens what he does is he says I'm
gonna go buy this I'm like no I don't
have the I I I can't I'm paying off
other stuff we're paying off other stuff
we we can't and he goes and and he does
it he goes and does it
anyway he does okay we have a side by
side it's paid for I I said you you
already have a paid for side by side
what is it worth yes
um
22 and it's used yeah okay and what how
much student loan that do you have H 55
oh okay so you have 100 and $115,000 in
debt and I paid for house and your
household income is what
100 it's 10 and this year I think it'll
be 162 oh okay that's excellent all
right well I mean you guys need to sit
down and not have a side-by-side
discussion you need to sit down and have
a marriage
discussion yes sir and say I love you
and I'm tired of being your mother I
don't want to be married to a little
boy who has to ask his mommy to make
decisions I want a man who stands beside
me and looks into the future and says
how can we Prosper as a family and puts
his own little selfish desires to the
side of the good of the family M I need
a man would you please find me
one and I'm going to make a call out
here here's just this is what I think
I think that you guys started making a
little bit of money and you started
doing may this is my guess a little
better than some of the the way maybe
you're you grew up and I think he thinks
you guys are rich and I think he thinks
this is what people with money
do am I right and especially yesterday
after we closed on the house he's like
we don't have a house P anymore I said
no cuz that's going to go to something
El yeah now you make 160,000 and you got
a stupid butt $660,000 camper and
$55,000 worth a student loan debt to
clean up and then you can go build some
wealth and then you can buy a side by
side if you want to upgrade your side by
side with cash when you're not in debt
anymore but that's what men do what
grownup women do not little boys and
little girls who buy toys that they
can't afford and this is the discussion
the two of you need to have uh hey I've
got a side by side nothing wrong with
them but quit buying crap you can't
[Music]
afford
J washaw Ramsey personality is my
co-host today thank you for joining us
America we appreciate you being
here Charles is with us in Evansville
Indiana hi Charles welcome to the Ramsey
show Merry
Christmas you too how are you guys
better than we deserve man what's
up so I
am um I have school student debt
16,500 uh $1,000 in medical
[Music]
debt and a couple bills uh I'm 23 years
old
uh I kind of just need like a a plan on
how to tackle
this all right so let's talk a little
bit about what you have coming in so
you've got this debt what's your
income so right now I am
probably making on average like5 $600 a
week okay I uh doing what I'm actually
on my I'm A Drop Berry technician by bar
cable okay so I'm on my two week notice
actually right now so what
happened uh just me and the manager
button heads just every single day I
just kind of felt like it was just
escalating and so what are you going to
do now for
money uh
I have a few places that I'm going to an
interview with one is uh
Aerotech all right um on the maintenance
side and uh the other one is for a golf
course okay first first rule is from now
on we're not going to quit a job until
we have another one lined up so let's
remember that for future for future use
because you got to keep money coming in
all right and what are I just felt like
I was about to get five fired really
that's what kind of made me well so you
fired yourself and put yourself in a
pickle you need a dad gum job Jades are
still right so what are these jobs you
applied for what do they pay I hope they
pay a little bit better right are you
are you trying to move
up uh yes I I want to um what's the golf
course
pay the golf course is 45 a year okay
and the uh Aerotech one the maintenance
position is 24 an hours starting out
okay I'll show about 45 okay okay that's
both of those are ER raised then good
when will you
know when will I know if you got them I
go for I I go to an
interview for both of them this week
okay this coming well Friday good okay
good tomorrow okay good good good all
right in the meantime I still want you
looking into something that you can do
in the in I mean you can go on your
phone and start applying for door Dash I
want you to have a lot of iron irons in
the fire right now in case something
doesn't pan out it's the holidays people
are about to check out here in the next
couple of days and you might not hear
back do you know what I'm saying there
there's the propensity for a big delay
here and I don't want you to lose two or
even three weeks waiting for these jobs
and not having money coming in so I want
you to start keep what you got but also
it's door Dash It's Uber it's looking
into some of that what can you start
doing quickly to bring in money because
at the end of the day you can't pay off
debt if you don't have any money coming
in all right you're living at home true
yes
okay and so that's what this is the
first thing is get money coming in and
then you've got two debts did you say
500 of medical
debt uh a thousand a thousand okay so
that's going to be your very first debt
barring I'm just assuming the student
loans is it one big one are you paying
payments on the student
loans uh no so that's my biggest problem
um back in May I talked to a lady from
Ed Financial
at least I thought it was and uh we
never set up like a payment plan or
anything but uh like this last month
whenever it started coming out yeah uh
they I guess they just set me up for 120
payments uh at like 140 150 bucks okay
so have you been making those
payments no no I didn't even know uh
they were due so from May all the way to
October uh me and my mom we couldn't get
a hold of them because she was trying to
do it too uh I guess because so many
people were calling in from the whole
Biden thing and there's nothing online
that you can log into no no and they uh
well that isn't sound right they told
they told me that that lady that I
talked to never worked there and that
they had no idea who I was talking to
but I received stuff in the mail from
them saying I'm like pass due
$400 and then if I don't make like a
payment by the end of
December okay so collections when it's
time to it's sounds like she enrolled
you in a plan and you just didn't
understand the details cuz it sounds
like you haven't paid and now it's due
when you look at that bill where do you
have to go to pay it it lets you pay it
online right there's somewhere where
you're logging in you can see your
balance you can call their phone number
and pay it from there I understand that
but I'm talking about you with your own
eyeballs being able to log into your
account see the balance see what's due
see the interest rate right cuz you got
to be able to see that no I I can't see
that
now I have it uh all that stuff on paper
that they uh sent they didn't send you a
website link with the with the
collection's
notice no so what happens when you you
need to go look again bull crap I'm if
you need bull crap you need to get the
paperwork back out there's a website on
yeah it's 2023 it's ed.com or whatever
whatever it is it's somewhere on there I
need you can't get in front of this if
you don't look at it and there's part of
me that kind of feels like you're don't
want to see it right so do your research
I'm confused because I talked to him on
the phone okay and on the paper it says
I'm not confused you haven't paid any
money to them and they want some
money it's not confusing can you guys
explain to me the interest though CU it
doesn't matter it doesn't matter you owe
16,500 you need to get online get your
account set up and start paying them
$1,000 $2,000 a month right quick as
soon as you get some income coming in
you're living at home you don't have any
bills let's get these people paid off by
August get them paid off get them paid
off by August but what Dave is saying is
you're going to pay this so fast you're
not going to care about the interest
interest rate doesn't matter you're
going to pay eight $2,000 a month and be
done in8 months in interest $2,000 a
month and you're done in eight
months okay you hear me 16,000 bucks
right 165 you're done in N
months you're saying it went up to 26
did I just hear that yeah they're
telling me that I'm going to owe
$111,000 in interest the time my payment
bangs up yeah by the time you pay 120
payments but you're not going to pay 120
payments you're going to pay it off by
September that's right and so your
interest is probably about 7% on it
somewhere like that but you've got to
get online and start having an
interaction with account because the
idiots on the phone you have discovered
are absolute their parents are cousins
over there man this is the dumbest
operation on the planet you've got to
get interfaced with the website because
it's the only possible way you're going
to get ahead of this and then make a
place where you can make a payment and
you can log the payment and you can keep
up with the payment and start sending
them $22,000 a month I'm not worried
about you being in collections you get a
job you're making $40,000 a year you put
$220,000 towards this you're done in 9
months months mhm that's it that's it
it's say you're done quit but don't
screw around with it and sit and wait on
you know your mother to call them and
fix this get your butt in gear and get
in there and get this solved run
headlong into it like your hair is on
fire quit waiting on somebody else to
fix it cuz I'm telling you the people
you're dealing with are dumber than a
rock and that's the thing you can't and
they don't care and they don't know like
they're not your financial adviser
people call into the student loan
companies and want them to tell you like
the student companies have one goal keep
you in debt exact they don't want you to
pay it off yeah don't ask they want to
make it difficult to pay off what I want
to do is to get a knife and stick it
right straight in the middle of this
account and let the air out of this
thing right now and get after it this is
an extreme level of proactivity like it
matters because it does a little bit of
energy on your voice there man get a
little fired up about it like these
people are freaking stealing your money
and they're getting ready to mess you up
for the next decade of your life if you
don't quit screwing with them go punch
them in the face man get after it get
you some money coming in and attack this
thing with a Vengeance this stuff has a
high rate of Resurrection it doesn't go
away cuz you talk to a mystery lady last
summer on the phone you got to get your
butt in there and give them money lots
of it quickly so they go away that's how
this works you got to find a way to do
that best way to do it is online cuz
you're not having to deal with an idiot
human on the other end of doesn't want
you out of that
[Music]
[Applause]
anyway
[Music]
every dollar is our worldclass budgeting
app it helps you manage money the Ramsey
way it works wherever you are with iOS
Android or online you can start every
dollar for free and immediately see
where you stand with your money you get
organized you personalize your budget
you stop over spending you save money if
you're new to every dollar we'll show
you a long-term Financial road map
showing you how your budgeting app is
going to take you right through the baby
steps you'll track your net worth your
debt free date your retirement date baby
step progress more we're going to
actively coach you to build wealth to
reach your goals download the free app
for iOS or Android or go to
everydollar.com and get started you can
do it for free or you can do the every
dollar plus and connect to your bank or
you can go all the way to ramsy plus and
do every dollar plus included with
Ramsey plus with Financial Peace
University the whole thing in a package
and uh that's a cool thing too check all
of that out at Ramsey solutions.com or
everydollar.com either way and for those
of you that have mint or know someone
that has mint uh it's a very large and
um popular budgeting app uh it is
closing in a
week they're shutting it
down yeah and we're one of the other
largest budgeting apps uh we've always
thought ours was better uh now we're
sure it is cuz it's open
so so uh uh inviting uh all you mint
people to come over and uh come come out
come out of the dark side come to come
over to our side come to the light
that's right that's right come to the
light we we will help you out we promise
you and spread the word guys you can go
to Every dollar.com Jade and you can get
a deal I think it's $15 off you can get
I got to get me a SL Dave I know or I'm
going to give these folks some options
because I need them to get into every
dollar or check this out if you buy the
book money is not a math problem the
book's $10 but you get three months free
of every dollar premium cuz there's a
little QR code in the book so these are
now yes yeah there's ways there's
methods to get this yeah so SL Jade gets
you a few dollars off but $10 for the
book get you the book and you can do
that at Ramsey Solutions and boom there
you are you get three months free hey
that's a good deal we got options here
lots of things lots of things Riley is
uh not there on that line Riley would be
on this line in Iowa City hi Riley
what's
up hi um how you doing better than I
deserve how can I
help so um I'm I'm me a bit of a of a
pickle right now um so me and my wife uh
we were together for a few years and
then got married this year in August and
um now
we're uh I'm in the verge of getting of
a divorce and I just you've been married
six
months yeah what in the world son how
how what's going on
W um so yeah we we were together for
three years and we we were I it felt
like we were creating something you know
we had our own place it was a an
apartment um we were working towards
getting a house and stuff and we
eventually had our daughter uh who was
currently Oney
old um and then we got married and just
a few days ago um I found out she
cheated on
me um and I don't know I'm just like
kind of just stuck right now I just I'm
not 100% sure what to do I'm sorry H
that's
terrible what a horrible thing um her
and I like have talked about it and
she's willing to definitely do like 5050
with uh with our
daughter um I just just don't know how
I'm GNA financially cover this um
recover from this because I I I I've
never had the best worth ethic I always
had trouble keeping a job um I was
always just kind of just battling my
mental health and stuff and um I haven't
been now I have my daughter and I just
how old are you I'm way I'm 22 okay do
you have any dead
hun no okay I don't have any de that's
good news okay so what you have um is a
broken
heart and a little baby
involved and um you are going to be
forced to stiffen your
backbone and start having a manly career
going forward and putting your life
together aren't
you yeah but but you don't feel you
don't feel real strong right now but
you're going to have to be
anyway I don't I mean luckily like I
have family uh uh your family's not
going to do it you're going to do it
you're 22 years old you're going to
throw your shoulders back and you're
going to get through this I know it
hurts but you're you're your this is
your time this is your
moment when you decide everything's
going to be different for you from today
forward you're going to step up and you
you know because here's the thing work
ethic is a
choice you can just decide
today I'm going to be a different guy
today I'm going to have work ethic today
I'm going to show up today I'm going to
have energy today I'm going to have
initiative today I'm going to pour into
my career and I'm going to turn and put
the this horrible heartbreak in the
rearview mirror and I'm going to go make
something of my life you're only 22 you
got the rest of your life to go be an
incredible
man I feel like that's just one issue I
have with myself is I I feel like I'm
already on time and you're 22 I know I
got socks older than that you're not out
of time you're not out of time CU if
you're out of time then Dave and I are
screwed
Dave might be out of time but Jade and
you are not out of time no we're good we
I got I'm not out of time I got I got a
lot of time left life is good have at it
so you too man so listen I listen the
problem with something like this is a
broken heart steals your confidence
yeah and I'm trying to tell you you need
that confidence and work ethic um these
are
decisions and it's very difficult during
a time of high trauma high stress to
throw your shoulders back and just get
get after it but it's the best medicine
for where you are it's the best healing
you'll
have go lose your work in some 80h hour
weeks go lose your life in some 80 hour
weeks and see how big a pile of money
you happen to pile up while you're
recovering from this mess then this
broken heart and you move
on okay man what I would tell my little
brother my tell my son yeah if he called
me and it was in a
situation it it's there's not there
there's not a it yes it hurts but gets
some of your best have you got some good
friends some good man
friends I I do yes okay are they studs
or are they
wimps um they're studs okay then then
tell them come around you and you need
somebody to walk with you right now
you're hurting
yeah I've been there myself where I'm
hurting I need some guys by me I need my
I need my family by me tell me it's
going to be okay and pushing me and
saying Go Get It Go Get It Go Get it cuz
otherwise what human nature is and I've
been there I was 28 years old lost
everything I was sitting in the corner
sucking my thumb whining about how bad
life was and one of my buddies goes you
need to get your butt up and get moving
it's what he told me he said you got
enough lemons here you ought to go make
some
lemonade and that and I did I've
been I've been I've been working I I've
been keeping up with the builds and
stuff um it's just uh it sucks because I
I I really like this job and what do you
make enough I make about uh 17 an
hour okay I want you to go make I want
you to go make
$100,000 quit limping along Go Get
It Go Get It you're just 22 go get it
you made a mistake in this relationship
you chose poorly she broke your heart
now go get you a life get it it's only
thing you can do it's the best possible
reaction to this horrible tragedy mhm
this is the ramsy
show
[Music]
our scripture of the day is Psalm 37:21
the wicked borrows and does not pay back
but the right ious is gracious and
gives the great Milton fredman said
nobody spends somebody else's money as
carefully as he spends his
own that's true it's also true of the
government yes okay Kevin in Austin
Texas hi Kevin how are you Dave Jade
good to talk to you guys you too Merry
Christmas hey Merry Christmas absolutely
I got a quick question for you um so I'm
27 single I live in Austin Texas the
home prices out here are astronomical
I'm in baby step 3B I saved up about
50,000 for that down payment and I have
about 10,000 in an emergency fund um
you're in good shape well done
appreciate it thank you sir my question
is is that uh I'm still single and my
good buddy Roy has been saying for a
long time Kevin ain't no one is going to
want to date you when you're driving
that old Honda Accord you need to get
you a sports car what your good buddy
Roy is an
idiot oh man I love Roy I really do I do
too but Roy don't know how to pick a
woman if a woman is going to come to you
because of the car you drive you're not
get much of a
woman oh man word I pretty much agree
with you wisdom in a multitude of
counselors I'm I'm going around um dude
I was on my third date with my wife in a
1974 Monte Carlo and we went AC I was
telling her that some I had $2 to my
name
and I was telling her someday I'm going
to be a millionaire and we went across
the railroad tracks and the muffler fell
off my
car we've been married 43 years wow
she's been through bankruptcy and been a
millionaire twice riding around with
that guy with no muffler on his car yep
absolutely tell Roy not to not give any
more women advice oh man I I agree with
you on that I do but I I also have a
little bit of a bug I'd love to have
okay now we're getting to it Ain got to
do with women or Roy blaming it
on on okay now we got I'm a stickler I'm
a stickler and I don't spend the money
on myself like that so I don't know is
it okay what are you try to what you got
to fever for what you got to fever for
Kevin well I'd like to get me 2016
Camaros that like might have some miles
on it you know something fun sweet
what's it
cost uh I I I was thinking about pulling
about 30k out of the down payment and
taking that to go get me a toy is what
I'm doing well what do you earn every
year what what do you earn annually
120 all right so and you're single yeah
we've established that you're looking
for a woman yeah okay that's right um
all right so listen if you make $120,000
a year you have $50,000 in cash and you
want to delay as a single guy I don't
want to buy a house right now we're
going to delay buying a house and we're
buying a car that is used and is way
less than 50% of my take-home pay that
fits the Ramsey guidelines yeah I'm
locking in my vote I like that now you
don't think it would be cuz I earmarked
that money I put it in for a down
payment well that's that's why you
earmark it so it makes you stop and
think you are
trading two years of buying a house for
the
Camaro okay that's what this ear marking
does it makes you make that decision and
you put both of those on the scale two
years on one side of the scale Camaro on
the other side of the scale but what
you're describing in is not an outof
control purchase nope unless you're
buying it to get a
girl oh yeah no I just which we've
established just a bad plan true but the
car is a sweet car there's nothing wrong
with it it's not a it's a good car I
love the car but the uh uh you know and
you know it's not going to make you
happy it's a reasonable vehicle purchase
in your
situation um it is going to delay what
you're saying is I'm Trading two years
of my purchase on my home goal for this
purchase of this car what are you
driving
now uh it's a 2014 Honda there's nothing
wrong with it mechanically it's a mom
car about 10 grand okay so you only
really need 20
grand yeah yeah that'd be true oh that's
good look I'm excited for you enjoy the
car okay all right I appreciate you guys
I gotta pray about it wisdom in a
multitude c y one but but but don't buy
it to get chicks you'll get the wrong
chick you're right you get you'll get
one you don't want shallow women are not
handy shallow men are not handy and
people who pick dates out based on cars
are the definition of shallow look it's
not going to hurt him though let's be
honest
Dave shallow co-host I'm just saying
it's oh my gosh it's not hurting his
case it doesn't necessarily help his
case but it's definitely not hurting his
case that's all I'm
saying women weigh in and weigh in in
those com it's not hurting him please do
not pick a date based on the car they
drive the car doesn't make the man
please man makes car please God help us
all I'm just saying the same guy if he
rolls up and you know his Honda Accord
wasn't bad I don't know why he thought
that that was Jesus car Jesus said
they're all in want ACC
Court you just can't argue with this if
you wanted to buy a Tesla you wouldn't
have been on board though if he wanted
to buy a Tesla but a Tesla's not a chick
car not even close a Camaro might be I
mean not a 2016 oh yes it is it is is it
it's a boss car yeah well then that's I
then I I stand my claim he is not
hurting his case he's not Hur in this
case but don't let that be your
motivation it's a bad thing it's a
really bad idea if people are impressed
by what you drive instead of who you are
you have the wrong crowd you're running
with especially the wrong woman you're
day so just you got to get P listen that
when you reach the point you're driving
a car cuz you want the car that's when
you're making proper car purchases when
you're trying to impress somebody a
stoplight you'll never meet that's when
you do stupid butt stuff with cars you
think everybody else is looking at you
oh come on nobody gives a crap about the
end day I nobody's looking really nobody
and if she's looking I don't want her
it's it I'm just saying that's how that
works and that's official dad jokes
right there all wrapped into one
official Boomer Boomer insights and so
into dating Boomer insights Boomer
Boomer dating insights that's what that
is we're going to have a new a new a new
segment on the show James next year
Boomer insights on
dating I'm sure I'm sure we could get a
sponsor like
depins okay okay Dave all
right uh Jasmine in Denver help us how
can we help you
Jasmine in Denver um are you there yes
hi hi how can we help right quick before
we run out of time we can hear you so I
was I was in a car accident uh on April
and it was really horrible we got a new
car are you okay that uh yes I'm fine
now thank goodness um we have a we got a
settlement we got $38,000 from that and
um we me and my husband we had some uh
credit card bills but the first thing I
did pay that all off no anymore we used
to owe 12,000 so now we're all gone and
we have like a little bit of money left
I still owe my car
23 and after that I still owe like some
furniture about like 5,000 I want to pay
that off as well um I've been listening
to you guys only for like about a month
or so so like I just like just by
listening on the radio I was like all
right so maybe this is like the stuff
that I need to be done but I don't know
what to do next and then also like uh I
want to make more income so I've been
working at restaurant as a waitress I've
been moved to the company company's been
nice to me but um they said that they
they're thinking about promoting me to
be a manager but jine what's your
question has been like should I move to
a new restaurant a higher restaurant
that pays me more or should I stick with
this one hoping that I get promoted to
be a manager and make more money what's
wrong with going to the one that's going
to pay you
more I what the downside accept it or
not they might also promote you to a
manager if they're willing to pay you
more so that was easy yeah that was easy
and then list those debts from smallest
to largest and if you have any money
from the settlement put $1,000 aside
keep it get after the um get after those
Debs yeah and you sound like you started
that process but let's finish it up now
and then make all you can make and throw
it all at that uh at those debts and
work them off in that direction well
Merry Christmas
America I feel like we really got after
some people today that was that wasn't
the Christmas spirit I was expecting
well the Grinch is here what can I say
oh man wow January will be better that's
fun Kevin's buddy Roy bless his heart
Roy's been hanging out with uncle boo
boo that's true that puts us our the
Ramsey Show in the books we'll be back
with you before you know it in the
meantime remember there's ultimately
only one way to financial peace and
that's to walk daily with the Prince of
Peace Christ
[Music]
Jesus
n